Раніше цей катер належав Військово-морським силам США.
Нині ж боронить річкові води України.
Він оснащений сучасним навігаційним обладнання
та стрілецькою зброєю.
Це справжній мисливець за "шахедами".
Та нічого не відчуваю, збив і збив.
Так скромно про свою роботу розповідає Андрій.
Хоча насправді кількість збитих ним російських безпілотників
вже й не злічити.
Що день, що ніч, що глибока ніч.
Працювати в будь-яку пору нормально.
Якщо сонечко - дуже добре.
Якщо дощ - це вже трошки гірше, але справляємось.
Катери річкової флотилії на службі у Військово-морських силах України
вже понад рік. Скільки їх всього - інформація засекречена.
Утім, офіцери кажуть, катерів треба ще більше,
тож сподіваються на підтримку від міжнародних партнерів.
Адже основне завдання флотилії -
захист Києва, а також Київського та Канівського водосховищ.
Річкова флотилія почала своє формування торік, у 2022 році,
коли ми зрозуміли, що загроза є і на водних шляхах
з території Білорусі та з території Росії.
Ми відновлюємо наші вікові традиції присутності на річці Дніпро
військових об'єднань, підрозділів.
Маючи такого агресивного сусіда з півночі та з північного сходу,
нам необхідно бути впевненими, що контроль на водних ресурсах
здійснюється постійно. І саме для цього задіяні ці катери,
і вони виконують місії абсолютно на 100%.
Приміром, саме завдяки роботі річкової флотилії
росіянам стало важче вражати дронами північ України.
Адже раніше під час запуску безпілотників
Росія активно використовувала русло Дніпра.
І саме наша присутність на річці Дніпро
перекриває доступ вздовж. І я думаю,
той досвід показує, що робота досить ефективна.
Росія почала використовувати іншу тактику застосування "шахедів".
Якщо раніше вони напрямок і пріоритети
виставляли по гирлу річки, то тепер вони намагаються
знайти шпарини із сухопутних коридорів.
І цей фактор показує, що річка - це не просто "that's easy",
як це було раніше для них.
Можливість ось так постояти та поспілкуватися з журналістами -
рідкість для екіпажу. Зазвичай військові як не російські безпілотники збивають,
так українських порушників ловлять.
Всі кажуть: "Ми знаєм, ми знаєм, але хочеться на річку".
Хочеться рибки половити чи в романтичну подорож поїхати.
Ми зупиняли й таких.
Але, так би мовити, це не виправдання.
Заборона дійсна для всіх.
Зупинити ми можемо будь-який катер, бо наразі заборонено пересування.
Якщо якийсь катер їде, то ми зупиняємо й перевіряємо відповідні документи
для перетину річки. Якщо їх немає - катер затримується,
а екіпаж відправляється до поліції.
На службі у флотилії переважно річкові моряки,
які багато років пропрацювали на Дніпрі. Саме цей досвід
допомагає їм під час виконання завдань. Крім того, серед членів екіпажу
є й цивільні моряки, які ще донедавна ходили в море.
Повномасштабне вторгнення застало мене за кордоном.
Я перебував в Індії й повертався потім з Кореї,
бо через коронавірусні заходи неможливо було повернутися з Індії чи Китаю.
Я повернувся з Кореї і приєднався до лав Військово-морських сил.
Останні 10 років Антон був капітаном цивільних суден.
Утім, 24 лютого залишив кар'єру, аби стати на захист України.
Тікати, ховатись - це дуже неправильно.
Роботу знайти можна завжди, а батьківщина - одна.
От 24 лютого, коли оголосили повномасштабне вторгнення,
ти бачиш, як твоя країна зменшується.
Кожну хвилину, кожного дня.
Як гинуть твої знайомі, як зруйновано твоє місто.
Залишатися осторонь просто неможливо.
Відповідно це рішення далося дуже швидко й дуже легко.
І я про нього явно не пошкодую.
Єдине, що гнітить - розлука з рідними.
Адже служба займає більшість часу.
Екіпажі цілодобово патрулюють Дніпро.
Крім того, на деякі бойові завдання йде до трьох-чотирьох тижнів.
Більше часу проводиш з екіпажем,
ніж зі своєю родиною вдома.
Сумую я за роботою? Ні, не дуже.
Сумую я за сім'єю? Так, дуже сильно.